you're always condemning I
mean I
mean once understand this record about
Starbucks when the war
starts second day I didn't
know I had a cup in my hand yeah someone
contact
me the case then you are utilizing
something
to you are utiliz which
is
Instagram I have no problem with Bo
boy me now the owner of pure gy came out
openly and he support
what I have membership which I go late
night I go like 3:00 in the morning I
don't know I don't know which one I
go so what happened now I can't now I
have a clear proof this man is
supporting the people causing committing
genocide against our brother so I made a
video to boycot Pure gy but never is if
the brother doesn't do it I don't I
don't doubt his belief just telling him
what you're doing this is because why
this guy openly came out since not even
in the beginning in the beginning maybe
it's not clear what's happening inaz now
it's clear to everyone there's a
genocide the Zionist are having no mercy
on children women and babies so how on
Earth you coming out and you supporting
these evil people in understand so what
I did I come out I made video and I said
I now some Muslims they want me to be
like sheep if I tell you boy this you
have to if you don't follow me you're
support of Zionist first you can't
establish this company support of
Zionist yeah if themselves came out say
we don't support
them so what me to do I have to follow
you but when it's clear to me I done it
and I don't believe boycotting in Muslim
countries you can do it individually but
to call out for everyone to boycott this
goes back to the leaders but us in non
Muslim country more non Muslim country
we don't have no
leader so I did it encouraging the
Muslim Brothers out there if you have PG
membership cancel it cuz this guy openly
is supporting yeah these not already in
Google no he openly came see I'm not
guess boting you understand but you
cannot force me to boycott something and
you ever give me proof just I have to
follow people are not sheep you know
many Muslims sometimes they not many is
bigger some Muslim are sheep they follow
Bo and Bo you want to boycott after you
like I boycot pure gym if I see brother
going to Pure gym I would advise look
that's only that is cheap for
me I'm going to doubt his Bel as long he
makes for people if he has the money
support financially
lot of De with
watch got especially Tik Tok I I I had a
little not even debate I'm not even on a
level of debate I had a chat with
discussion with Joseph the
Jewish yeah yeah Joseph yeah he took one
little clip out there yeah that guy that
guy to show corrupt that guy I used to
be fair me and like we speak to each
other when I found that supp the so isra
stop talking
to cuz I first I don't believe in a
country called Israel that doesn't mean
I don't I call for genocide Jewish
people cuz there's many Jewish people
don't accept the country called Israel
you understand and I don't even accept
the two solution State I
don't I don't how can how someone can
call shami Zionist when I don't even
recognize a country called Israel and I
don't even say want to do with
Algeria me personally now me personally
I don't even accept it our necessity may
be the same because they're weak me I
don't accept it but yet is look how much
can you like you know he's not even
accepting the name of the country how
can you tell him that he's one of them
accept them I recognize their
country we you because people cannot
refute us with knowledge so they have to
light they have
toer happen enough people like and gu
ass
and when you're back in Saudi you're
more back in Saudi the part of it being
our focal point and main point for Islam
is a Muslim country and I know there's a
plan there is a plan to spread
Revolutions in the Muslim countries to
destabilize it and destabilize it the
new version instead of sending troops
they did it in Libya they get an
opposite
part and guess that am I with Haram no
it is
but we don't deal with it by like
spreading theam calling toell and you
know like like you know ABD first how
did he rebel against not with a sword he
start spreading the mistakes
of he let people know yeah naturally
people start what they call it
generating hatred yeah yeah hatred
hatred then they start thinking what we
have to do this to him that's the only
way you understand so that's how he
starts people influence very
social
media how he
Prophet with a
tongue so that's why I don't I don't
justify Haram har is har okay yes
sometimes maybe some countries they
would do something which we
call they can cause Haram to remove the
greater Haram less har in order to
remove greater Haram and this issue of
countries and Leadership goes back to to
the leaders and the schol not
me I'm just going to tell you what Allah
said mam said and and the Banning you
know lot you got watch out you hear out
a lot of his rumors it's easy to believe
what people are telling you over there
Banning of you know Ramadan they said
Banning of eating I'm just saying these
little little things that
bring just you know what I mean to say
these little little um say they keep
thei that's problem SCH and our ownes